look a reindeer is just a game moves so
say it's not let's go I'm just sitting
on your front porch wondering how could
I be so far oh man and my mind is
somewhere else but when I found it
our patch up where it's been grown now
I've just float on the breeze and I feel
like these leaves that must be
but when I reach that I'll share this
peace of mind I can defeat it thought
it's gonna take
for me to staff that talking
my cellphone
shy
[Music]
find a song I'll sing it just oh yeah
and that is shine by Bishop gun right
there and and it is February 24 in the
year 2020 and then we're getting into
the future aren't we you know a lot of
people didn't think we'd get this far
into the future
like I think if you dug up some people
who are deceased or something and you
said hey hey hey wake up hey wake up how
far in the future you think we'll go I
bet a lot of them would not have picked
this far but we're making it we're
making progress
that is a shine by Bishop gun and some
bad news came out of their camp last
week that the band has canceled future
dates as of right now
and has taken a bit of a break a
sabbatical I don't know what their plans
are I tried to get in touch with with
with my little nephew over there to see
what was going on with them but hadn't
gotten too much information and that's
where we are but man I would hate to see
uh see them not be able to make it
happen because they got a beautiful
little outfit beautiful little musical
outfit right there and that's Bishop
Gunn just back from Toronto ha I want to
thank everybody who came out that was
just man it might have missed some of
the most hype crowds I mean people just
one dude out there he was just so fired
up dude he had a um he was he had I
think was just donating his own blood
into a bag and just threw a bag of it up
on the stage
people were hype and it was magical man
we have four shows over there at the
Queen Elizabeth II ater sold them out
and thank you so much can at a beautiful
Canada for coming out and people I
notice in Kent is so friendly
like people apologize all the time I'm
sorry we sorry who's sorry sorry one guy
came across a parking lot I'd never even
seen him and he goes all sorry okay so
he's like case I ever bump into you I'm
sorry
so why it's almost like people are just
trying to be out or they're like they're
like they're trying to have like a
polite off go you think you're sorry bro
I'm sorry er do them and I don't mean
sorry like as in incapable or not gonna
fare well are not gonna do something
well I mean sorry as in oh oh my bad you
know oh it's okay you know
oh yeah but yeah they're like all sorry
and they're like oh you think I'm sorry
I got a friend that's even sorry uh-oh
oh this guy he's so up he or he
apologize he apologize always always
he's so apologetic I'm the most
apologetic mother gone around people
just like I'm sorry jumping off
buildings I'm sorry uh I guess huh but
anyway people just so polite and a good
time and just such a great time and
thank everybody for coming out and
enjoying it and enjoying the just the
joy man just a sheer joy in that theater
in that theatre and uh what else I'm
home I'm headed this week to Red Bank
New Jersey on February 27th that's
Thursday Oxon Hill Maryland February
28th and Newport News Virginia February
29th those are sold out and then we got
the
castle theatres on March 7th in Maui and
the Ryman Auditorium in Nashville on
April 17th and there are still tickets
for Maui I believe that Nashville is
sold out so that's crazy man I can't
believe when we get to go to the Ryman
do people some people treat their dogs
like a slave
you notice it so I went to the park this
morning to get a little bit of heat a
little free heat from the sunshine you
know a little bit of that vitamin D
straight from the vitamin G OD you feel
me I'm talking straight off the head of
the Lord the sky and just catch that
free heat right in my face and net and I
went over there and I was just sitting
in the in the grass making me a little
gratitude list and doing a couple of
outings and stuff on the UM I'm one of
those legal pads you know and this man
heard this old man he's like char he
goes Charlie got over ere sure char like
get out of our hair
and I thought it was too you know kind
of drug-induced or you know drug-induced
homosexual men doing uh you know
splitting up a you know a gram or a vial
of uh a vial of speed but then I look
over in this man who I'll be honest this
man looked like Doody bro this man
looked like just man just real just just
duty duty and he's yelling at this dog
because the dog smelled something worse
all it is and the dog he's over there
he's investigating you know he might
have a little bit of hounding him or a
little bit of uh investigator gadget or
whatever that guy's name was remember
that show but the the dog he's you know
he's sniffing on an orange peel or doing
something you know we're smelling um you
know a part needle or something or
whatever and a man's like shards get all
this yelling at him
and Charlie first of all Charlie was way
healthier this man looked like just
first of all looked like somebody has
shaved his whole body with like a 1 or
like a 1 and a half he had a fade like
on his arms shoulders everything crate
just real bristly looking dude kind of
guy he looked like he was like a pipe
cleaner you know one a member of pipe
cleaners remember in school sometime if
he was one of the weirdo kids and they
at the art class they would give you
these pipe cleaners and say hey do
something with this and you'd be like
what do I do it it like I we don't
notice do something we hope when you
graduate soon cuz nobody could stand you
you know and um and yet is dude young
thinking man this dog and then so then
the dog comes over by me and now I'm
kind of pissed cuz I'm sitting there
trying to do a little bit of um legal
work or whatever you know right and
stuff and drawing and this man's charlie
leave him alone I said dude I said
Charlie messing with me man I said you
messing with me by yelling you're
messing with everybody sir and [ __ ] it
just I don't know man and the dog went
over to him and I just felt like I don't
know when Charlie left dude I felt like
damn bro Charlie don't want to be with
that man and that man treats him bad
that's how I felt dude so but yeah
Charlie was like a big dog and I'll be
honest I slipped on a piece of nicorette
so Charlie [ __ ] get that hit from
Daddy right there so that guy can kiss
my ass Bob what I'm saying is you can't
your dog is not a slave he doesn't work
for you okay you can't you know say this
dude is Charlie get in the house no ham
hocks Charlie nothing for you you can't
be like that to an animal you gotta
treat an animal a little bit kinder I
think but I don't know I don't know
their backstory that [ __ ] just made me
mad I don't see a lot of animals and
stuff so in here in Los Angeles so it
just made me kind of kind of upset by
anyway what's going on man good to be
here I feel a little bit rattled it has
been all over the place and um and I'm
so excited that all that we got these
shows coming up this weekend these are
make updates and just happy to be
getting them done these are the last of
the makeup dates except for Brea and
we'll do them some time what did I see
on the Washington Post the other day put
up a thing oh they were talking about so
Bernie Sanders is out there whooping
people's ace right on the circuit on the
political circuit and I'm not much of a
political I never you know ever since I
was young I've never I've never thought
a politician is or politics gonna save
my land them dudes ain't doing [ __ ] for
us you know I've always thought if my
bed's gonna be better I'm gonna have to
make it that way you know if I'm gonna
have a little bit of uh you know if I'm
gonna have a little bit more nut in my
squat you know a little bit of a little
bit more gumption in my scrotum you feel
me that I'm gonna be they have to want
to put it in there I'm not relying on
the government or something to make my
life better but uh but it just blew my
mind how suddenly they came out with a
report that now that Bernie Sanders is
winning in the Democratic you know
regionals or whatever it's called
semi-finals or whatever but that Russia
is helping him and I'm just like you got
to be kidding me with this [ __ ] you got
to be kidding me
you telling me that this dude that every
time somebody starts winning Russia
helps them it's just the worst excuse
man it just made me like it was just
like it's almost like sometimes the news
thinks that we're so dumb it's like you
really think I'm dumb enough to believe
this the last time Donald Trump was
winning Oh Russia helped him oh this
time Bernie's hello Rush
help them it's like whoever they don't
like they make up this story I don't
know man
it just blew my mind I was like do you
really think maybe humans are that dumb
maybe I'm maybe I'm dumb for thinking
that we're not it just and how was how
was how was our country helping somebody
win an election
they put ads saying even if they do put
an advertisement on internet if they
don't go in there and pull the far the
arm the volt the what does it call if
they don't pull the pole or whatever for
you if they don't tab you vote if they
don't do the voting for you then they're
not doing nobody could do [ __ ] unless
they're making robots and send them him
and they're dressed up like people all
I'm just here to vote Charlie get off
get away from that guy anyway let's just
just have me riled up I was like you got
to be kidding me now you think that just
because this guy's winning that they're
gonna that the Russia it just made me
it's like oh how does for somebody would
just you almost were somebody who just
burned down one of these news places cuz
it's just [ __ ] man but what are we
to do man what are we to do I got
nothing Oh what else happened this
weekend let's take a look at the
hotlines people called in from the
Toronto show and I'd love to hear some
thoughts and some awe some reactions and
um here we go how did you know this is
Lisa calling my friend and I were lucky
enough to see you Friday night in
Toronto for the Early Show oh thank you
for coming out there Lisa and you got a
friend - I'm glad you and your friend
came and that's nice if you got a friend
you go do something Oh me and my friend
are doing this oh we're having we're
splitting the cabbage we're splitting um
you know we're doing a tandem bike
so homework and I just had to call in to
say we had so much fun just laughing our
heads off everybody around us is just
doubled over laughing I mean I've been
to a lot of shows but I've never laughed
that hard that a comedy show but genuine
question when you're up and look and I
hate to interrupt you but sometime the
laughter is it could better bring it out
of you it's that it's almost like an
exorcism but a good one it'll make
something come out of you a secret
sometimes people laugh so hard they they
tell a truth about themselves they let a
secret loose some guy the other day he
laughed so hard at the show and he's
just like he came out of the closet he's
like ha ha and his body's like Patrick
dude what are you talking about Patrick
have another beer man your wife's gonna
pick us up in about 20 minutes - she's
gonna be pissed bro have two beers
Patrick and calm down bro you're gonna
be fine you got to get back to your wife
and kids man so you don't know somebody
you know somebody sometimes that giggle
will just wiggle something right out of
you it'll just shake a truth right out
of your frickin lie booth right out of
the back of your brain you'd be like I
killed somebody with a shovel I love
licorice people just you know I don't
wash my husband's clothes but I tell him
I do so he's always wearing dirties you
know you just sometimes when that
laughter get you Lisa it can really
shake something out of you
it can shake the mainframe and that's
when maybe a little dribble of some
truthful just leak out of your feet you
know your sudden you'll suddenly you're
slipping a fact about yourself do you
never want it to admit I like to smell
uh my own ass you know something or
something like that you know sometime
you'll just a truth upon just just whip
right out of you that you don't want you
know
I've been saving all my back hair that I
shave off in a bag under the sink in my
bathroom ah you know it just that's what
can happen might it smell like
tangerines so anyway a lot of truths and
and and and non uh and old secrets can
come just right just avalanche and out
of your frickin brainstem let's hear
more Lisa up on stage can you hear how
hard were laughing like are you able to
get that positive feedback from us
because I mean every sentence you were
saying at one point everybody was just
dying laughing man it was it was just
incredible so thank you so much for
coming to our neck of the woods thanks
for everything
well you guys have a beautiful neck of
the woods up there and Toronto and I
never thought Canada was real when I was
young and I've said that before dropped
my keys you know I thought I thought if
you died in Canada you woke back up in
America that's something that I thought
or that I'd heard or that I just thought
and then pretended like I heard you know
I thought maybe um or Canada was just a
place that they practice safety
equipment like if you ever saw a helmet
or some knee pads or uh you know if you
was at doing the bumper bowling and they
had the special lanes on the side for
the kind of kids that had a hit of that
Tisza more just youngsters that wasn't
used to push him ball and say all all
that's from Canada but as far as the
laughter goes you know it's really you
can looking you here
sometimes I feel like I talked too fast
and I step on people's laughter in a
comedy club I'm so used to that I'm more
used to the area and so I know how to
manage that room size of a room better
when it's about 300 but in some of these
theaters you get upwards you know a
thousand two thousand it gets tricky and
I can't see anything when I'm up Dhaka
see maybe the first two rows kind of and
then it's just lights it seemed like
somebody you ever been outside and
somebody's pulling a boat up on a dock
and you're like oh are they gonna Park
this thing or that it's gonna shine that
light in my eye
for an hour it's like that it's like two
people are parking boats but none of
them will part they're just it's like
okay park your boat shut off the light
or it's like two motorcycles coming at
you diagonally and the lighter just
hitting you so you can't see if you kind
of have this light in your eyes so
sometimes it feels like you're
performing too it's almost like it's an
experiment or something like there's
just you hear like a lat like a kind of
like the sound of laughter but mostly
you to see these two lights and you feel
like you're just performing into nothing
almost it's really bizarre
so sometimes it's nice at the end of the
show or some of the beginning the the
the light man will pull thee will bring
the lights up for a second and then you
can see everyone and it's it is a 180
from what you've been seeing the whole
time so some of the people will react or
do something in the audience and if I
don't react to it I can't see I have no
idea what's going on most of the time
but but man it was so much fun there was
one moment where they brought the lights
up it was on Saturday I think and and
man I felt like but it I just felt
people were having so much fun and
cheering it manages
I don't know I just felt it doesn't feel
like it's for me I guess it just feels
like people having a good time but it
just felt cool it was like wow this is
something just fun to be a part of so
I'm just glad you guys had a good time
Lise I'm glad you and your friend came
out and and enjoyed each other's company
you know there is something nice after
the show if I get to see some people and
stuff and just you know knowing people
had fun man it means a lot you know we
had a young one young gentleman this
Italian and we used to call Italians
we'd call him head lice when I was young
because they showed up in groups and
kind of bothered you but uh this
beautiful young Italian he had a tall
friend with him real long Italian one of
the male eyes and they uh he came before
shows and I think he had just knocked
this girl a beautiful young fellow I'm
not sure his name was Tito or something
or - uh and and I don't know antiguo I
have no idea but I can't remember but a
very nice young man knock on wood I
don't know what his name is but and I
don't know what no I don't even know why
I'm knocking on wood um what else but
that was good it was a good time there
let me hit let me hit this other hotline
call came in nine eight five six six
four nine five zero three what's up T oh
I'm here with my friend Sam it was so Co
gang game what's up Sam
gang brother and there's a lot of people
named Sam in Canada I realize that
homework we just drove from Montreal to
see a show in Toronto the Friday night
shows to be specific and brother some
[ __ ] [ __ ] and it's right behind us
are you and the yelling and stuff I
don't know what happened but you kind of
addressed that you said the person
you're like what's going on and for some
sets of like cut you're like oh you're
cutting yourself the crowd just died but
it was a great show man I don't know is
people walking around and [ __ ] but like
don't like that in the way those dope
yeah I just want to know where I felt
about the show because I remember at one
point you kind of stressed out and you
know what do you got
I don't know but we love you till Vaughn
and we're here to support you so let us
know extinct thanks gang gang voice a
gang gang uh dude thank you guys for
driving man I hope y'all made it home
safe man if you didn't make it home safe
than you're you're in heaven bruh so
either way you want it man it was
wonderful you know candidate the the the
general feeling I have when I'm in
Canada is such a feeling of safety you
know uh in America I feel like there's
always a little bit of uncomfort I'll
like it's and maybe it's just because
I'm in Los Angeles I mean like really
The Devil's Den here I'm out here in the
damn Devils dimple just feeling him grin
and whenever he wants but in Canada
there's just there's just a friendliness
there's a not everything has like a wage
to it not everything has like a like a
like there's just something more genuine
about it
it's really really it's so pleasant to
be around
so yeah dude I just had I had such a
great time I mean I had such a great
time it's going out and people are just
they're having a good time there's
there's just there's more of a ease in
people it's like somebody just put a you
know two cans of ease and just squeezed
it right into somewhat everybody's neck
everybody's just eased up not like that
guy at the park was like get off Charlie
there'll be a shed or whatever that guy
was do they need a police need to get
that man because he's treating that dog
like a damn indentured servant but uh
but yeah I mean it was just a blast man
it was just it was just I'm trying to
think of a better way to describe it but
I mean my stress level has been high man
I can't I really can't wait to take a
break you know I used to feel you know
honestly I used to feel a lot more
dialed in even when I was doing the
podcast it was easier for me to connect
and to kind of drop into what was going
on but I just I have been under a lot
I'll just just stress just a lot of the
traveling and stuff
and I don't talk about it sometimes even
though I do a lot I feel like because
once you kind of start doing well I feel
like once you start having some success
nobody wants to hear you complain really
nobody you know it's like so it's
sometimes that kind of that stuff it's a
little tough for me to talk about that
some of that stuff recently because I I
feel like nobody wants to hear the dude
that's doing well nobody wants to hear
him complain you know but but yeah I'm
trying to take more methods to deal with
some of my stress a little bit you know
I flew in a day early in a Toronto so
that I wasn't jammed up on the same day
of the show having to travel and then go
straight to the show I'm gonna go to
Maui in a few weeks and hopefully have
some few days to just get connected to
nature just stretch out be an ostrich
put some puts my legs into the sand and
be like that maybe maybe see said you
know it's hid in the distance or
something you know maybe I bring Charlie
with me if I see a nice tit in the
distance have him go get it char Charlie
oh god oh man that goth stripper dude
I'm gonna start calling Charlie next
time on her impersonate the guy I'm a
hide behind the tree in the distance and
when he says something to Charlie I'm
gonna say something no you're doing fine
charlie
you're doing great you got the day off
um let's take one more call that came in
right here homework I see it was poppin
off it's still out here in Central
Oklahoma
what's up dingo thank you for calling
man that's a rare name brother but then
but then what homeward
I was just scrolling through the
Facebook and I saw kind of a
heartbreaking post that uh Bishop Gunn
was going to be hosting all activity I
guess they're going
some struggle I thought so I'm sure the
guy that introduced them to us I would
give you a call and see what your
thoughts are and you know hope that they
hear this and know that you know there's
a lot of people that care a lot about
them and we hope they can work out
whatever it is that they're going
through and come back to this you know
anyways love you Theo you're the best
man and you can do it you're good enough
you worked all your life for it thanks
man
thank you Bros nice a nice that's nice
you to say that yeah man it really makes
me say I do you know I saw that post as
well on Facebook and uh yeah just you
know I want the band they're so good man
I really believe they're so good you
know when they've worked so hard and
they've done so many shows and I think
some of the strut stuff that from what I
from my perception it seemed like some
of the stuff they're struggling with is
just internally between them and they're
trying to figure it out and I hope that
they do man you know I don't want to
take words out of their mouth I asked I
asked burns sharp the drummer if he
would call in today and I don't think he
was up for it so I'm gonna see if he'll
check in next week and maybe give us a
little bit more information but yeah
just heartbreaking heartbreaking madness
it just shows you how ray or something
when something's good it's rare man what
something is good it is rare and then
you think there's gonna be all this this
could happen again easily or this could
happen again in a moment's you know
something else could happen something
better
but we don't want to it's something we
don't want to settle but it's why I
wonder why we don't know why we aren't
able to notice when something is really
perfect and I struggle with it you know
I think there's going to be something
different oh I've got you know maybe
there's a better opportunity or maybe
there's someone better
[Music]
but thanks for saying I'm good enough
man I appreciate that you know it's
funny sometime when I'm on the stage and
the lights come up a little and people
are cheering it feels I feel like like
almost like turning around and looking
behind me it's like who what are they
claw is there somebody you know is what
is this full you know it just I mean I
know that that people are there and
they're excited and they're excited to
see the show and stuff but I don't know
it's interesting man but yeah hope
Bishop gun gets it together man I really
you know I love the vibe that they have
and just they got this soul they got
this soul eNOS maybe if you have a
thought about that when we get to the
hotline call about practice and kissing
and how people did it in just a second
but if you if it was if there was
something good in your life if there was
something when you had something really
good and you let it go you thought
there'd be something different and you
thought there'd be something better or
maybe uh because our ego can be so
dangerous you know the ego is you know
our ego starts running before we passed
the baton a lot of times and I just
wanna maybe and maybe nobody will have
anything but if you do hit the hotline
with that nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three and and I love you
guys man I just want to tell you that I
love you and thank you oh you know one
thing I just I don't know man I've just
said you know you guys have all helped
make my dream come true you know to be
able to make people laugh at a big at a
level and if this is the greatest my
career ever gets and this has been
amazing and
you know I'll just feel really blessed
but I'm realizing it takes a group
really to make a blessing you know
so gang I want to let you know that
today's episode is brought to you by
Power dot and you can see this sweet
item right now if you're on the youtubes
there now power dot is a specialty item
here and it you know one of the worst
things about working out and training
and being real aggressive and just pump
in your body and making your body pump
hard and pump blood and get muscle right
is the recovery because if you think
about it imagine if you could tear open
your skin you'd see all your your
muscles would all be laying in beds and
havin Gatorade and probably doing a salt
suppositories and whatever they could to
rehab rehabilitate themselves quickly
but one thing that can help that is a
clinically proven muscle stimulation and
that's where power dot comes in these
people know what they're doing over
there power dot puts a modern spin on
clinically proven muscle stimulation
it's the first of its kind it's built
around an intuitive mobile app that
provides the user with great preset
programs designed to speed up recovery
improve athletic performance reduce pain
and rehab from injury it comes at your
stem cell package man not stem cell but
it's your cell stem package
this thing will stimulate your muscle
cells I mean you could always spend a
ton of money after you've worked out and
hire a masseuse or you can create your
own and control your own with a
different pad you can put them on
different parts of your body you can be
at the office and rehabbing that sore
quad you could be I mean he'll you could
pack nine I'm on you're on your butt and
put in that booty work and stimulate
that body that butt body area tighten up
that back butt
you can do it all traveling with powered
out is extremely convenient by removing
the control unit and connecting via
bluetooth to your mobile phone the
actual unit itself fits easily into the
palm of your hand it comes with all the
pads you need it comes with the app to
connect your phone it's simple and it's
effective it's used by the best in the
world throughout the NFL NBA Major
League Baseball NHL and MLS that's
soccer even Tour de France cyclists and
CrossFit athletes use power dot control
your own recovery and for our listeners
power dot offers us customers a free 30
day trial plus an additional 20 percent
off that's right just for this past
weekend listeners go to power dot-com
slash Theo that's powa RDO t dot c om /
th EO and use the code theo at checkout
for 20% off your order that's power comm
slash Theo and use code Theo for 20% off
your order
Rehab yourself get it done power dot
look do you want a little you want a
spoonful of brisket sometimes at 11:30
a.m. you want somebody to drop by your
house and just hum a creme brulee right
into the back of your jaw or in your
back jaw you know what I'm talking about
post mates why not have somebody on a
bicycle come by and just frisbee a
pancake right in your fat stepmothers
gullet when you need Redwine at 4:00
p.m. sushi at 6:30 and a breakfast
burrito at 9:30 and ibuprofen at 10:15
well obviously something's wrong with
you
but something's also right with you
because you're using post mates post
mates is your personal food delivery
grocery delivery whatever kind of
delivery service all year round don't
you want some Charlie anything you're
craving posts mates can deliver the
largest on demand Network in the US and
offer delivery from all the restaurants
grocery and convenience stores and
additional retailers and all you could
possibly want or need 24 hours a day 365
days a year that is as much time as we
know post mates will bring you whatever
you need within the hour
download the app for iOS and Android for
free browse restaurants and businesses
locally and track your delivery in real
time you can see where oh where is
hotter - oh he's a half a block away for
a limited time post mates is giving our
listeners $100 of free delivery credit
for your first 7 days
support this past weekend try post mates
if you haven't - start your free
deliveries download the app and use code
weekend
that's code weekend for $100 of free
delivery credit for your first 7 days
when you download the post mates app
anything you need any time you need it
post made it download post mates and
save with code weekend support the
podcast if you can thank you guys for
all the love now last week we was
talking about kissing smooching and I
talked about a couple thing when I was
young you know when I was young not
everybody knew how to kissing people was
it what it weren't the first way you
knew to say hey to somebody first we
need they teach it a handshake and
that's basically saying hey let me touch
it real quickly let me touch you say
okay I'll let you touch me but just my
hand I say okay that's an agreement
that's a handshake and then they do a
hug they won't I'm gonna trust you
enough to put both your hands around the
around and touch my back really quick
while I touch your back okay and go boom
okay that was good and then it gets to
another level though when your body
starts to get hot when your loins start
to look around you feel me
because when you're a man and you're
young you can only look around with your
head and your neck
but at a certain age your Weiner says
hey I'm about to peek around as well and
that is cold what is it called
uh her berty that's almost full pervert
ooh baby that's when you're getting lit
brah that's when you suddenly lit for
some tit dude but what I'm telling you
is this what I'm trying to say is that
we all started practicing away kissing I
shared about mine last week and so you
guys had some calls that came in and I
want to hear a couple of those here we
go getting high feel this is mofo from
Idaho what's up mofo what's up mofo from
Idaho and Idaho is a good place if you
want to uh if you want to get kind of
wind burn on your face and sunburn at
the same time and if you want to look
for gold but not find any but still
dress like you look for gold
then Idaho is a beautiful spot great
place to get sunburned and uh and go
missing as well a lot of missing people
in Idaho all work so I'm the youngest of
six so I had older siblings and we had a
Barbie head that was like a head and
shoulders and neck so you could do her
hair and her makeup like it was like a
mannequin head so when I would get a
chance to be alone with this Barbie hi
we practice kissing I think we're alone
now that doesn't mean to be anyone oh
okay so you kissed that little baby uh
that baby a Barbie let me hear more on
her neck and her face and everything and
amasa turning me off a little wha - a
got me tricky dude this is gonna bring
old Patrick out the closet you feel
magic let's hear him want to back it up
a little bit in a second he's tell me
what happened again homework the chance
to be alone with this Barbie her hobby
practice kissing on her neck and her
face and everything and it always it
never failed every time I went to do
that one of my siblings would
catch me and be like mo are you kidding
the Barbies net and I'd be so [ __ ]
embarrassed and so that would just go on
and on and also uh you know the poles in
the basement I used to put on my roller
skates and like swing around the poles
and practice kissing on those and again
somebody would always catch me and be
like what are you kissing the pole
anyway so funny ah yeah okay look
everybody's got away you know that's
interesting you kissing plastic humans
and you kissing poles you know that's
really could work at the mall I mean
yeah it almost sound like he could work
at the mall um but yeah there's
everybody had a different way you know
some people would do something different
man I had this boy living across the
street from us named Robert and he would
put his hand in the hot water and get it
real hot and he would make that kind of
kissing area like a little lips with his
hand where you put your curl your
fingers in your thumb across the front
and then he would kind of kiss that when
it was all warm and everybody had a
little something we would heat up the
oyster you know where every now and then
things got a little bit homosexual with
the key you know if it's young fellas
they kissing on each other's neck a
little but when you're when you're child
anything gay is not gay gay is just
children you know I remember find out
too I found two of my nephews one time
in the bed and they in their butt naked
so what am I gonna you know they're
children and one of them had a bunch of
damn uh little Hershey's Kisses it in
there would he had to hold em stack
couple them on his belly and stuff
something and some of them were melting
a little bit and the chocolate was
getting on his skin but what am I gonna
you know that's nothing that's children
all right let's take another call that
came in here hey Theo this is hope I
used to practice Kissin on an apple I
would take a bite
I would take a look like a little like a
little Dibble out of the Apple and then
you know it would leave like a little
hole for like you know you could put
your tongue in there and boy man that
[ __ ] got me feeling some type of way you
know you see out there getting that
fruit dog putting your tongue into that
fruit boy you could have at least had a
little bit you know you could have cut
open the orange Brian curved out in that
sucker I used to do that when I got a
little bit older I'd dig out the middle
of the turns and throw three of my
fingers in that bastard let's hear more
it was kind of a sweet treat at the same
time mmm so that was kind of how I used
to practice kissing when I was young and
I really like the podcast man I really
like your really like your concept and
keep keep doing you baby boy gang thanks
Colt I like that I like a man named
after a weapon as well Colt you know or
maybe who else ninja star
and if you don't think there's probably
a young black woman out there named
ninja star then you're probably wrong
maybe bad girl
kiss on Apple let's hit let's take
another one that came in how you
practice getting that lip lock and going
gang hey Co I'm going all the way from
Pennsylvania damn from PA and that's a
much country if you want to see what
your grandparents did drive through PA
man you get out there out near uh what
are some of those areas out there
waiting Amica smell the butter you could
smell the breast milk and air I mean
these women got some breasts on them -
that's the breast belt do you be driving
you hit us to be like what is that a
speed bump on Interstate black nah man
this is a couple of titties crossing the
road out there cuz it's that kind of
place man and they got skin just so
milky my god that milky skin I mean just
make you want to just something god damn
every titty look like it down
everything looks big and good out there
but there's nothing like a real milky
breast you know a lot of times they try
to push these days they push these
different type of breasts this and that
you know oh here's that lean titty rock
witty what a lean titty people want the
rest the breast is supposed to be the
breast you know you know I mean when I
was growing up we had a lady that worked
at this lady we live in apartment for a
little bit and it was for apartments in
one big building and we would play
football in the backyard out back and
they had this that big area and we get
out there and just be our just pretend
we were heroes you know and you had
different you know yet a whole in a
certain part yet to go around and they
had drainage coming off of somebody's
laundry room so you had to be careful
and if somebody's running their dryer
that hot air was puffing out of one area
so that's where we would do the intros
beginning of the game we say off but
starting quarterback and your boy would
come running out of that dryer smoke
from the bottle laundry room and then we
played a game but they had a lady who
did a verbal sex work by us and she was
like a hotline worker back in the day
they used to have if you called on the
phone line you dialed one 900 big titty
or something a woman would answer and
she would like yeah yeah you know this
is uh this is Diane you know this is
Diane breast or something like that you
know this big titty what can I do for
you and she would sit there and she
would like talk oh yeah let me I'm like
I'm taking your pants off right now oh
yeah you know oh I'm choking you right
now I'm you know I'm all spitting in
your bellybutton
you know why like oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
I'm hiding olives and yeah you know
they'd be get real nasty and stuff but
she was doing verbal sex working every
minute she kept the person on the line
she would get more money for the family
but one of her windows her window is
down by the other end zone where we
played football so you didn't even want
to go score down there sometimes when
she was getting real vulgar you know
she's like oh I got three olives I got
three olives in my ass you know you're
like oh I gotta I'm making martinis it
in between my you know she'd be just
getting crazy
oh yeah she'd be down there yeah give it
to me like what's going on all right
let's take this call that came in right
here here we go hey Theo I'm calling all
the way from Pennsylvania and this
regards to your last podcast stop
practicing your kissing and I used to
take a nice juicy soft
mango just bite a little small mouth
hole in the side of it you start making
out with a mango let me know what you
think damn boy you sound like a pervert
bucko what do you you sound like do you
doing something while the mango first of
all mango is the straight-up [ __ ] of
produce you got to think that maybe
think when other when tomatoes see a
mango coming Dayne saying oh look at its
thought over ha you do think about that
you don't think when two peaches they
sitting around on the swing set just
peach and you know maybe splitting up a
percocet or something and then they see
there's Mitch mango get out of a taxi
you know they both think and look at is
you over here I'm telling you bro mango
is a stray slew of the fruit kingdom
gang bro thank you for calling ma'am and
get out your mama's refrigerator but you
sound like you got to stay home if you
being like that homework hasty oh this
is all done I'm not in the Bay Area
California I was just listening what's
up old done thank you for calling
brother Oh work into your podcast and it
made me think of how I used to practice
kissing I used to make out with my elbow
pit on the inside of my forearm and I
used to kiss it I used to [ __ ] him give
it hickeys and everything dude that was
my [ __ ] I think I did it for like a year
everybody knows he did it for way longer
too even though you just said that but
all her brother
and then I don't know why I stopped
doing it but I haven't thought about
that many years thank you keep up the
good work
I love the positive message you bring
with the humor attached dang bro
Thank You Man thank you very much thanks
for calling man look
you making me think I have a limited
neck my neck I got a medium medium to
lower than that you can bear if I look
for something I can't look really long
because I got a I got bringing my neck
back to Center
I got a recenter my neck some people got
that neck they over here they over there
they doin laundry they lookin for this
you know I'm saying they own the Lost
and Found they could they could do
multitask with that [ __ ] big Reacher
with that fifth [ __ ] limb baby that
neck but my [ __ ] limited time I got that
limited look piece baby so I couldn't I
couldn't really get into the crease in
my heart my elbow very much but I bet I
did try let me try it oh yeah now that's
the second I put my face there I'll
remember I definitely did oh yeah man
damn dude in my do a mile vogue crease
taste like it remembers me to you boy
then this this chick is fine as hell
dude and I remember even this dude this
is Oprah verse I can't even leave I'm
telling you this as I got older
sometimes sometimes my underarm which
had to vibe the scent of a woman to it
and I would sometimes put my face right
down in there and like get a couple of
Huff's off my own off that own my own
[ __ ] little reach crevice right there
that armpit and then I would use that
you know I fueled myself to pleasure
myself you know antennae and do
masturbation
so damn almost was trying to said that
but you know what whatever man that's
who I am that's who I am dude because I
wanted that full-body experience because
sometimes one of my underarms one of
mine arm always smell a little bit got
that spaghetti kind of that Italian you
know it's something under there and I'm
running like a Primavera you feel me but
every now and then one of my arms had a
bit more of a kind of a fertile feminine
kind of you know it kind of had them it
kind of had the same tenor the same kind
of uh the same hit that you get the same
hit off of it you would off of a woman's
body and even maybe a vagina even if I'm
being real honest with you and I know
this is grossing another's kind of
graphic man I'm sorry about that I'm not
trying to be disgusting I'm just trying
to be honest with you but uh but so I
get a couple hits at at and then I would
use that because that would get my brain
all fired up with that hot pouch you
know it would just it fueled that
because I would have that that vit that
uh the scent I had that scent of a woman
right under my on that who uh you know
and so I get a couple hits at and then
use that to power my my my ability to
touch myself but yeah man we all did
something and it's okay that's nature
nothing wrong with you and there's
nothing wrong with me man we got a
couple more that came in and I got to
tell you about this last ad for the
episode when you're selling online
getting your orders out can be a real
pain what's that pain oh that's getting
my orders out how do you keep track of
who gets what what carrier should you
use are you getting the best rates
that's why you need ship station calm
it's the fastest easiest and most
affordable way to manage and ship your
orders just a few clicks and you'll be
managing your orders printing out labels
and getting your product out fast to
keep your customers happy ship station
makes it easy
shipstation helps you get orders out
save money on shipping costs and keep
your customers happy no matter what
you're selling on Amazon Etsy eBay your
own website it brings all your orders
into one simple interface no more going
to PayPal and printing out the thing and
taping it to this and then where does
this go and then who do I now I got to
run them all over to the post off you
can put it all together simple interface
take your shipping to the next level it
works with all the major carriers
including USPS FedEx UPS even Amazon
Fulfillment
no wonder ship station is the number one
choice of online sellers and right now
this past weekend listeners can try ship
station free for 60 days when you use
offer code théo there's absolutely no
risk you can start your free trial
without even entering your credit card
info just visit ship station comm and
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in Theo that ship
station dot-com use code Theo ship
station make ship happen oh these are
good man let's take another one right
here how you got that smooch hey get
that smooch practice cuz look some guys
lucked out some fancy guys if he was
real rich maybe your mom come downstairs
and give you a little kiss or something
to stay heavy with you if you had a
stepmom
maybe she sleep over once a month or
something you like damn I don't even
know what that is for he's just a bank
because I'm the one me around are seeing
each other now
but before but if that wasn't your case
then you had to learn to kiss somewhere
and if somebody wasn't kissing you had
to find a way and that's who I am and I
appreciate you being similar let's go
they don't call about the practicing
kissing here there's young I think I was
in sixth grade you know you finally
merge flaws with life or different
elementary schools you got all these
girls I was AI need practice I would
take on hot shows
mm word they melted a shallots then sit
down and there was a faucet I would like
to pair like here on your first director
to the bath and you've turned to a
shower but uh you practice on that boy
you know let's move a little bit was
crawling with shine he said I might give
it a little tongue kind of sick girl
because your own reflection guy goes
right in just picture a nice woman but
all right that's all dang bucko
that's one way to do it man and that's
how you wind up selling AHA and that's
how you're gonna sell a bathroom
equipment for the rest of your life man
with that kind of love for the game
right there but yeah I could understand
we can see your reflection in something
and then you go kiss it now if you
sucking on the front end of a ball of a
faucet that might be kind of homoerotic
you might be getting a little bit
homoerotic alrea right you might meet a
man hell you might end up dating the Tin
Man
you know if somebody in the next room is
watching Wizard of Oz and even through
the television that Tin Man sees you
sucking on the end of a frigging
dripping faucet boy yeah boy that mad
metal maniacs and a pop right out of
your screen bro and he's gonna want his
uh he's gonna want his chrome polish
daddy look stay safe out there man
wherever you are I am saying that and
thank you for sharing thank you for
sharing that that let's take another
call man let's take one more call that
came in here to the hotline I appreciate
you guys being so supportive I'm excited
about going to Maui in two weeks if you
have a friend on the island tell them to
get to get that hitter man grab some
tickets
what else he I just need I'm ready to
have a little bit of break man I feel a
lot of stress in my shoulders I can't
it's like like a tingling that's in my
shoulders in my neck and I think I might
be allergic to coffee too so you know me
dude I got all the problems baby I'm
wearing this Joe Musgrove today too son
got this beautiful hitter right here
Pittsburgh Pirates said I'm one of the
best in the game right there gang bro
gang there we go
hey Theo this is amber from Illinois I
just wanted to call to address the
zookeeper that was on in the last
episode so I work for ecological
restoration and I think it's the
zookeepers having some ethical dilemmas
about working at the zoo that ecological
ecological restoration might be a good
option friend because you're helping the
animal you're helping kind of improve
the areas where they live and get rid of
all damage done by humans to the natural
areas and you're also you know still in
the outdoors you're not having to work
inside or anything you still have a
positive impact on the environment
without all the ethical dilemmas because
you ought to see animals being
mistreated and things like that
yeah now look I feel you there I now
appreciate the call last week we had a
gentleman he was really you know while
he was coming to having us come to Jesus
moment about um working at the zoo and
not like in the system but I'm ready to
say this that uh that yeah some animals
get mistreated in zoos and things like
that I mean I saw blackfish and I don't
know if you've seen that but it's about
I guess what if the how they treat
blackfish and the [ __ ] is I mean I shits
it's a little heavy man
you know it's like kind of like twelve
years a swimmer kind of but this um but
some animals learned dope [ __ ] let's be
honest you got animals down there at
SeaWorld and at a wally world or
whatever they'll spend a while you know
spin a ball on her nose
none of these bastards out in nature
doing that [ __ ] they fightin and you
seen planet Earth but a lot of animals
are out there beating each other's eyes
let's be honest I'm not saying they're
not beautiful and that they shouldn't be
allowed to do it but some animals are
learning useful skills as well there's
not it's not just a one-way street but
that is a great option man ecological
restoration I just say let animals go if
we want but don't be shocked you know
what I'm saying when little Bridget gets
[ __ ] clothesline by two orangutangs
and they want to be sexual or want to be
nastier so you know I'm saying don't be
don't come crying then when your cousin
gets [ __ ] shanked by an angry otter
bruh with a sharp palm when some angry
otter swims by at the YMCA in [ __ ]
you know what I'm saying Clips your
little kiddos tendons don't be Oh
what happened you can't have it all
there's a trade-off for everything so
next time you see a full-blown white
seal at you know over there at water
park and he can do the stanky leg that
ain't that bad man he ain't doing bad
but there's an option for you young
fella that called last week Eco
restoration and thank you young lady for
calling in and that's where I think you
sneak out into the wild and kind of make
things better for animals in this sneak
back and you're a zookeeper but you're
kind of like on the side so I'm curious
to see maybe I don't know if humans will
be around forever we might be something
that kind of comes and goes and then
animals can get back to whatever they
were doing here I bet they were dancing
before we got here but but I'll say it
is dude every now and then you realize
humans don't take that care good at care
of animals and that's why you got a
freaking slip a little Charlie a piece
of nicorette at the park maybe you feel
me boy Charlie gonna be Charlie gonna be
getting a buck every time he goes to the
park now boy he gonna be over there
running over there behind a federal
building trying to bum a Winston off of
some money he gonna be doing one of
them's in packs with Jesse Lockwood and
the gang thank you guys so much man for
supporting this past weekend uh and
everything you know we got some new
merch stuff coming up soon and what else
is going on a lot of neat stuff man we
need a single mom for coming up for New
Jersey and for Oxon Hill Maryland and
for a Newport News Virginia so if you
have a friend who is a single mother we
would like to treat her out to a night
out and and take care of her baby sitter
costs and and make sure that she can
have a night out of laughter and we want
to thank our patreon errs for helping us
support that program time and time again
we keep doing our best man we keep doing
our best that's what we do you know you
guys be good to yourselves man just keep
making and I'm gonna go out with that
with the bishop going cuz I hope they do
make it I hope they can figure things
out over there man it's a wild house ha
how how we can have so much talent in us
and have so much turbulence in us at the
same time
it's a wild to be on that balance I'm
amped up today man gagging you guys be
good to your salesmen this is making it
Bob Bishop gun
I've seen home in about a hundred days I
can almost hear mama bleep for my
restless soul and I ain't made a dollar
life spell but well aq me and I still
get where I'm bound go
wrong bacon
[Music]
and most all of my plans slip right
through my hands and walk up next to me
broken on
if their spiral was an hour glance I'm
slaving I'm about an hour care
I should've put it down
but how are you
[Music]
time
[Applause]
[Music]
but
I hate seen old men powerful to date I
can almost hear mama peel our recipes
[Music]
you